mais quelle est donc cette alarme qui a
retenti vers 14h30 pendant près de 45
minutes audible dans une grande partie
du centre ville de tours c'est une
question que de nombreux tourangeaux se
sont posés syrien sur le bâtiment en
face aux 35 heures
le préfet a très rapidement tuit et pour
rassurer les riverains et la cause a été
trouvée derrière la caserne des pompiers
de tours centre dans le quartier sanitas
je pense que c'est un déclenchement
intempestif puisque c'était pas du tout
programmé mon pour habitat maîtrise pas
bien évidemment le le déclenchement de
cette de cette sirène c'est une sirène
qui est là pour avertir la population de
danger grave on la sait habituellement
cette sirène est en essais tous les
mercredis du mois à midi l'as étaples
aujourd'hui c'était bien le premier
mercredi du mois mais s'est déclenché
dans l'après midi les pompiers ont reçu
plusieurs appels de riverains inquiets
mais le désagrément s'est arrêté vers
15h20 grâce à l'arrêt de la sirène par
les services techniques de la mairie